[Music]
they all know the way to the recovery
rooms at the hospital in kramertorsk
pass the sandbags on the ground floor
down the hallway to the stairs
on the second floor there's a couple of
doors we stopped at number two
it's like any ward in eastern ukraine
said the director this is what the war
has done
[Music]
alexander had just finished breakfast
when he almost lost his life
the russians hit his apartment building
in a multiple missile strike
now
little
[Music]
the doctors reattached his skin with
staples and applied an antiseptic dye
a distinctive color it covers his body
and that of his wife
[Music]
alexander has been joined in room number
two by his neighbor vitali who was
blinded in the same attack
he says there were two explosions
he walked to the windows after the first
one
it is a strain for his mother
vitali is a steel worker but he knows
his life will never be the same
must be a very worrying time for you
here
there's not much left in the building
where they lived
its contents have been expelled into the
surrounding area
six people were killed here another 28
injured
and we found a former resident sorting
through the remnants of his home
throwing stuff away he said i've just
got out of the hospital i came to find
my phones
[Music]
he told us that he'd been sewn up
his head his back
both legs as well
on the other side of room two we met a
man called vichislav who'd been admitted
with extensive shrapnel wounds
he said a rocket had landed in his house
but it didn't detonate
until his children touched it
his daughter dorina was seriously
injured in the explosion
this picture provided by the hospital
the surgical team spent five hours
trying to stem the bleeding
but they were unable to save her life
the man in charge said they did
everything they could
he'd brought her x-rays and placed them
on the window
look at what the war has done he said
dorina or dasha as they called her is
one of more than 140 children killed
since hostilities began
their acts of absurdity waged by those
who have lost all humanity
john sparks sky news in kramatorsk